today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video I've
spoken to you before about different
ways in which the world really has been
laughing at us for a long time since
Donald Trump became president they
laughed when we elected a president who
thinks climate change is a Chinese hoax
they laughed that we elected a president
who has no idea how economics or
currency or trade or medicine or the
Constitution or the law or public
transit or any of it works and they were
laughing at us early during the corona
virus pandemic and even as recently as a
couple of weeks ago many countries were
laughing at us I showed you about ten
days ago
articles from all over the world the
Netherlands South Africa Peru everywhere
ridiculing our moronic president for his
comments about bleach injections and uh
the the other things he said during that
press briefing but they're not really
laughing anymore now it has gone from
laughter to concern to actual pity the
emails I have gotten over the last few
days from our international viewers
people that used to be poking fun at
Trump's idiotic claims about vaccines
and the virus they now write to me and
say David we feel sorry for you that you
were dealing with this in the United
States we feel sorry that you are in a
situation where no matter what you do
even if you do the right things even if
you have the best intentions and the
accurate understanding of what it is
that's going on and what it is that's
necessary to deal with this virus we
feel sorry for you because your federal
government has failed they are
incompetent
there is no plan there is just a series
of Lies and disinformation and confusion
and bogus talking points and there are
even Republicans who are willing to tell
the truth they are increasingly agreeing
this is just some Republicans of course
most of them are actually behind Donald
Trump check out Republican strategist
Steve Schmidt explaining it again this
is a life
long Republican strategies take a look
Donald Trump has been the worst
president this country has ever had and
I don't say that hyperbolically ETS um
but he is a consequential president and
he has brought this country in three
short years to a place of weakness
that is simply unimaginable if you were
pondering where we are today from the
day where Barack Obama left office and
there were a lot of us on that day who
were deeply skeptical and very worried
about what a trump presidency would be
but this is a moment of unparalleled
national humiliation of weakness when
you listen to the president these are
the musings of an imbecile an idiot and
they don't use those words the name-call
I used them because they're the precise
words in the English language to
describe his behavior his comportment
his actions we've never seen a level of
incompetence a level of ineptitude so
staggering on a daily basis by anybody
in the history of the country who's ever
been charged with substantial
responsibilities Steve Schmidt Schmidt
is sadly absolutely right the presidency
is deadly and as more and more countries
open up it is us people in the United
States who won't be allowed to fly into
other countries because we're a mess
here as other countries are actually
dealing with the problem as Trump talks
about a super-duper missile we'll get to
that later that's actually a phrase that
he used his son goes on TV and says it's
all going to disappear on election day
because it's merely a fake political
scandal by Democrats as that goes on
here the world is taking pity on us for
our failed leadership I was trying over
the weekend to think of an analogy to
try to apply to this because there are
people who are analyzing this
administration as if it were a normal
administration you have these people
some of them are so-called enlightened
centrists who pretend to see both sides
and find things they like and Trump and
things that they dislike you can't
evaluate this president like you can
other presidents here's an analogy I
thought of that I'm workshopping and I
want to try out on you when someone says
about Trump well you know he has an
unusual way of talking about the issues
but he's right on deregulation and he's
right on trade but maybe he's not the
best guy on coronavirus imagine okay
this is the analogy imagine I was
playing in a chess tournament and I show
up and I replace all the Queen the pawns
on the board with Queens that I take out
of my pocket before the game starts
that's insane and it's simultaneously
making a mockery of the tournament it's
also cheating
I'm also either an idiot or a bad person
for doing it imagine that a chess
commentator sees me take eight Queens
out of my pocket and put them on the
board instead of the pawns and says you
know David's strategy is unusual but
it's certainly an aggressive way to play
the game
well what no that doesn't make sense
yeah I mean some players use the Spanish
opening and others take Queens out of
their pocket and replace the pawns we're
not talking about the same thing here so
when these enlightened centrists and
pragmatic conservatives and whoever else
when they pretend to do an analysis of
Donald Trump's presidency as if it were
even remotely normal they're failing the
sniff test on principle but there's
another issue here with very few
exceptions in the Republican Party they
are mostly just enabling this there are
a few Republicans who have taken a stand
and are saying this can't happen
right you've got people like Mitt Romney
who's a current senator from Utah
Republican you have George Conway a
lifelong Republican Steve Schmidt
lifelong Republican strategist there are
a few other Republicans I can't name
them all who have not softened their
view on Trump and they are straight-up
saying this is not acceptable this is
not normal this can't be dealt with in
normal terms because normal terms don't
apply I'm not talking about them but for
the most
are Republicans in Congress in the House
and Senate have enabled this most
Republican governors have enabled this
so Trump is not alone to blame here we
have to blame the 63 million Americans
that voted for Donald Trump yes they are
to blame it doesn't matter whether you
call them bad people or stupid or they
are to blame their actions are to blame
for what we were dealing with right now
of course Trump is to blame but the
Republican Party that mostly continues
to enable him that even before the
impeachment trial had already decided
were voting to acquit Donald Trump on
impeachment charges they have to be held
accountable as well we have the
opportunity to hold every single one of
the Republicans in the house accountable
in November we have an opportunity to
hold the Republicans that are up for
re-election in the Senate in November
which is of the 34 up for re-election I
forget the exact number of Republicans
but a number of Republicans are up for
re-election in November they have to be
held accountable as well we sadly have
to now have another sad conversation
we're start today's show at the start is
kind of a bummer but we're gonna get to
some interesting things if you bear with
me we have to have a really serious
conversation about the growing reality
that the conspiracy theorists are to a
great degree winning right now
surrounding coronavirus now I want to be
really careful here this includes
coronavirus related conspiracy theories
but I'm also talking about conspiracy
theories that are being floated now to
distract from the administration's
failed handling of the virus so I'm
going to talk about both things and I
should be clear that when I say the
conspiracy theorists are winning I don't
mean most people believe the
conspiracies that's not what I mean but
there's an asymmetric priority here when
I say the conspiracy theorists are
winning what I mean is enough people are
either falling for the conspiracy
theories or reporting endlessly on the
conspiracy theories such that it is
wreaking havoc on the overall
dissemination of real information
and distracting from a focus on what
matters and that's why when this
pond-scum nonsense starts to spread they
don't need to get 51% of the population
to believe it they don't even need to
get 20% of the population to believe it
they only need to do enough to wreak
havoc in the media and distract from the
real scandals really good piece in the
Atlantic by Jeffrey Goldberg which
actually goes into this and it goes
further and it says the impact of these
conspiracy theories winning is not just
on coronavirus but it's actually a
bigger challenge to enlightenment values
and to reality itself which we're going
to dig into there's also a piece and Vox
by Sean ihling which talks about sort of
the media's handling component and how
Trump uses the media to spread his
conspiratorial disinformation
specifically to distract from his
failings and we're going to talk about
that as well so first of all let's start
with Jeffrey Goldberg's piece in the
Atlantic and in that piece Jeffrey
Goldberg says Trump does not defend our
democracy from the ruinous consequences
of conspiracy thinking instead he
embraces such thinking a conspiracy
theory birtherism was his pathway to
power and in office he warns of the
threat of the deep state with the
ferocity of a queuing on disciple he has
even begun to question the official
coronavirus death toll which he sees as
evidence of a dark plot against him how
is he different from Alex Jones from the
conspiracy manufacturers of Russia and
the Middle East he lives in the White
House that is one main difference this
improbable question how did a person
with a weakness for conspiratorial
thinking achieve the presidency might be
among the most consequential of the
coming election which is not merely a
political contest but a referendum on
enlightenment values and unreality
itself nonsense is nonsense except when
it kills and conspiracy thinking
especially when advanced by the
President of the United States is an
existential threat and so when you think
of all the ways in which Trump supports
this new Khan
spiritism there are many so yeah as
Goldberg points out the big foray into
politics for Trump was birtherism
against Barack Obama this idea that
Barack Obama may not have been born in
the United States may not be may not
qualify for the presidency because of
the birthplace of his parents but his
entire trade politics were also based
around these sort of go too far ideas
about China and it went simply from
being about currency and intellectual
property theft into climate changes a
hoax perpetrated by the Chinese we see
it front and center on the virus
everything from Trump pushing
chloroquine is the cure what do you have
to lose from from very very early on -
it will just go away - the entire thing
that we've seen recently from Donald
Trump about just ignoring the fact that
there are people dying every single day
from this and of course with
conspiracies when there's a grain of
truth as there almost always is it helps
the conspiracy to grab a foothold we've
talked about this before the virus did
originate in China it just didn't come
from a lab it wasn't man-made in a bio
weapon Trump says it will go away well I
mean of course at some point it will
either kill everybody who's not immune
and then you've got herd immunity and
everyone who died has already died like
eventually it'll go away or we'll get a
vaccine or whatever the case may be
eventually it will go away that doesn't
mean that we just open up the economy
and do nothing and then Trump says well
some governors are being heavy-handed
that becomes armed protests by the same
people who think Bill Gates is involved
in some nefarious way to fund a vaccine
that will lead to a dystopian population
control nightmare that Bill Gates will
be in charge of and again just enough
people fall for this stuff that it takes
attention away from what matters and
from what's real keeping people safe
understanding when Trump is lying to us
minimizing damage to the economy in a
responsible way working together to get
past the lockdown phase and of course
just enough people fall for this stuff
that
starts to get media attention and that's
how they win they don't need to be
proven right they merely need to justify
their existence by getting just enough
attention and where we are seeing it now
front and center is with this Obama gate
stuff I'm I don't plan on covering Obama
gate very much I'm gonna do a clip or
two here or there for the purposes of
debunking what's being said but this is
how Trump controls the media Shawn
ihling for Vox writes Trump has been
able to essentially win merely by
turning the last week of right-wing
media and even some centrist and
standard corporate media into
adjudications and debates about Obama
Gate any minute that is spent talking
about Obama gate is a minute that they
are distracting their viewers from the
mounting death toll the failed response
the fact that South Korea and Taiwan got
it under control
right away and we did not we still have
inadequate testing levels and it's a
tactic that Steve ban and I don't know
that Steve Bannon invented it certainly
he probably did not but he uses it and
it's called zone flooding flood the zone
with this stuff and force the media to
cover it you don't need to convince a
huge portion of the public you just need
to get coverage and get people arguing
on one side of Obama gate or on the
other side of Obama gate and the media
have really not adapted to be able to
handle this as Sean Sean Owen says the
media aren't gatekeeping the BS stories
and to some degree media are allowing
more and more discussion of Obama gate
because it's ratings that's number one
to some degree media want more and more
discussion of Obama gate because if they
don't talk about it it'll trigger a
round of BS attacks against them look at
how bias they are Fox is covering Obama
gate fake new CNN and the Washington
Post won't cover it so part of it is
they don't want to be seen they're
scared of being accused of suppressing
the story altogether and the mere
discussion causes what we call the
illusory truth effect even if most media
outlets are bringing it up to debunk it
exposure to the
claims alone will get some people
believing them even if you do what you
believe is the responsible thing you
only bring up Obama Kate Obama Gate to
debunk it as the bogus conspiracy theory
that it is you are exposing more people
to the claim and more people may end end
up believing the conspiracy theory so at
least for now I'm not going to
participate in the Obama gate stuff
we're going to talk about it only at an
absolute minimum and we will talk about
it when there is you know a relevant
implosion by the right related to it our
audience also is not a general audience
it's people already following this stuff
but they win when they get enough of the
population talking about this stuff even
if they're not changing minds and the
real impact is that large swaths of the
country reopening in the middle of a
pandemic are doing so partially because
of these conspiracy theories about
everything from Bill Gates and
government tyranny and heavy-handed this
and that Obama gate distraction all of
this stuff is playing a role in getting
policy to be what they want rather than
what public health dictates let me know
what you think I'm on twitter at geek
Ackman and we'll have a few types of
follow-up on this coming up later today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Monica Bergstrom and Deborah
pare thank you so much to both of you
also want to say thanks to Nancy Meyers
who is today's longtime sustaining
member of the day Nance he's been a
member just shy of five years and I
really appreciate everybody's support
grab a membership at join pakman.com
you'll get the daily bonus show today we
have an incredible bonus show Pat has
what we are calling coronavirus
displacement part two to tell us about I
will also give you an update I've made a
180 on some of my recent prepping thanks
to some of our members all of that and
more on today's bonus show and you can
get instant access by signing up at join
pakman.com we could end the pandemic as
a pandemic by the 4th of July if we took
action right now wouldn't mean we have
no new cases certainly but we could end
the pandemic phase I guess we would call
it and I know that many of you know
we've already missed a number of
opportunities to do this back on March
5th I'm being very generous by looking
at March 5th we had all the information
we needed about the spread of the virus
we should have taken immediate action
Donald Trump should have said to all 50
governors listen we need a 50-state stay
at home order we have some very very
difficult days ahead but we will be
better off if we all do this now instead
on March 5th we did nothing on March 5th
we ended up doing only 500 or so tests
by March 15th we were still only doing
about a thousand tests a day by March
25th we were finally up to 80,000 tests
which was still not nearly enough we
were so behind and still to this day we
aren't doing enough tests and we don't
have any federal contact tracing
initiative so opportunities have come
and gone but once again we have an
opportunity in front of us to deal with
what we are dealing with right now and
we could be in very good shape
nationally by July 4th Alex Tabarrok
and Pujol haver wrote a really good
piece in the
Washington Post outlining the by pardons
bipartisan plan that they participated
in putting together and it's important
that this plan considers the medical and
the economic I've been taking the
economic seriously from day one the
right has been having a grand old time
framing leftists as not caring about the
economy as not caring about unemployment
not caring about economic destruction
the truth is I and most serious leftists
have been concerned from day one with
the economy and the reality is that six
months of rolling doclock downs in some
parts of the country some open-close
open-close that's not going to be good
for the economy either there's a plan
that's been written and the test the
testing element is a big part of that
plan we need to dramatically increase
testing how innovative it's not it's not
surprising but we are still not testing
enough but the test levels are very
specifically outlined by this plan we
need to be testing everyone who has
symptoms and all of their contacts
contacts and have enough capacity for
what we call surveillance testing people
just go in even without symptoms because
there's such a symptomatic spread we
need everyone who has the disease and
their contacts self isolate we may need
hotel rooms for people to be able to
self isolate depending on their
situation at home we may need stipends
for people who are self isolating while
they cannot work and what the plan does
that is really important is it divides
the country into three types of zones
green zones yellow zones and red zones
and the plan acknowledges which a lot of
right-wingers want that rural Montana
doesn't have to do the same thing that
New York City needs to do green zone
would mean fewer than one in 36 thousand
are infected you can do large gatherings
in green zones you don't need a mask in
green zones unless you are part of or
around folks who are in vulnerable
populations
you need one test per day for every
10,000 people in green zones and five
contact tracers for every hundred
thousand people that is not a lot for
the green zones now right now
there are not very many green zones two
weeks ago we could have had 19 million
Americans in green zones based on our
testing levels right now we don't have
any active green zones that are meeting
these requirements then we get the
yellow zones yellow zones are for most
of the country right now 298 million
Americans right now would be in what we
call yellow zones that's where the
disease prevalence is somewhere between
point zero zero 2 percent and 1 percent
okay in the yellow zones the economy can
reopen mandatory masks for everyone and
you need 2,500 tests tests for each
daily death plus much more contact
tracing you need to have enough contact
tracing to contact every person who's
been in touch with an infected
individual within 12 hours why within 12
hours because if you wait three days
it's too late and those people have been
going around potentially spreading the
disease so for example based on the last
few days of deaths New Jersey would need
250,000 tests per day but Maryland would
only need 87,000 tests per day these are
much bigger numbers than what we have
but these are not cartoonishly high
numbers based on on the models that
we've seen so you've got your green
zones and your yellow zones then you've
got your red zones red zones are there
more than 1% of the population is
infected right now there are about 30
million people in that situation that's
just under 10% of the country so in
those red zones you have everything that
the yellow zones have in terms of
testing and tracing but you also have a
stay at home order if you follow it the
red zone becomes yellow relatively
quickly by four weeks in most analyses
and then you move to yellow and then the
whole country could be at minimum at
yellow by the fourth of July
that means the whole country could be
open although yellow zones would still
have more precautions like mandatory
masks and we could be at Green by the
end of the summer we're not even close
on testing we're now testing about
350,000 375-thousand a day we need
somewhere between 3 and 5 million a day
and base
on current numbers were nowhere near
that this can be done but we're way
behind if we started today we could be
in pretty good shape for moving red
zones to yellow and yellow to green
heavily around the fourth of July seems
to be no political desire at the federal
government
Trump's acting like we won he's talking
about SuperDuper missiles but this is a
plan that works test race and isolate
North Korea I'm sorry
South Korea succeeded with it the
earliest New Zealand did it Taiwan did
it Greece had a milder version and they
still did it although it took a little
bit longer Greece's looking at opening
up for travel very very soon
prevention is cheaper than the cure
testing is cheaper than both the
economic destruction and the costs of
treating way more sick people
here's another plan the plan is based on
right now it's mid May we could do this
we could be in very good shape by July
4th you all know that I don't subscribe
to the polling conspiracy theories that
you can't trust polls that polling is
fake that polling is somebody in an
office making up numbers that the polls
only call old people on landlines I
don't subscribe to any of those
conspiracy theories because they're
bogus and we know that they're bogus by
looking at methodology
well done polling especially when you
average a bunch of good polls you get a
really good sense of where erases look
at 2016 Hillary was leading the national
polls by three point two she won by two
point one that's within the margin of
error that the polls were correct
nationally in 2016 now something really
dishonest was done by CNN last week with
a poll that they did and I want to call
it out CNN announced that in
battleground states Trump is winning 52
to 45 now as a savvy news consumer you
should immediately say what what does
that mean 52 to 45 across battleground
states are you saying that you added up
all of the different people in those
states and in total Trump is winning by
7 do you mean that his average lead in
each state is 7 are you waiting those
results
for the populations of the what does
that mean because states are different
populations different electoral vote
values well if you look at page 9 of the
CNN poll the methodology page actually
says for the subset of 583 adults living
in the 15 battleground states there is a
margin of error of 5.3 percentage points
so first of all you've got a sample that
across 15 different battleground states
is only 583 people total now that could
be 38 people for state not a good sample
size some states maybe had more of that
sample and some less because of their
population and the margin of error is
5.3 so this could be essentially a tie
or Trump could be leading by 12 this
tells us very little but the most
important thing is that this poll when
it says Trump's winning in these 15
states by 7 it doesn't tell us how far
ahead Trump or Biden are in any
particular state what I mean is
Georgia's included in these 15 states
well Trump's winning by Georgia by
around 8 right now 7 or 8 is Georgia
even really a battleground Georgia has
16 electoral votes it's not really in
play for Joe Biden why is it included
and how is it skewing these results some
other states that are included are
actual battleground states like for
example Nevada it's actually sort of
close Biden is +4 but Nevada only has
six electoral votes so how are you
waiting these different states and what
does it mean that Trump is winning by
seven across the states this poll
doesn't have very useful information and
unfortunately it was picked up on by a
bunch of right-wing media and even some
left-wing media and it is being spread
like some kind of gospel so let's do
something that makes more sense let's
look at each state one by one and then
total up the electoral vote so when you
actually break this down Joe Biden is
winning Arizona Colorado Florida Maine
Michigan Minnesota Nevada New Hampshire
New Mexico Pennsylvania Virginia
Wisconsin and then on the other hand Don
Trump is winning in Georgia Donald Trump
is winning in North Carolina in Ohio
the point is when you add up the
electoral votes in these supposed
battleground states regardless of the
combined population as of right now Joe
Biden would get close to 75 percent of
the electoral votes from these 15
battleground states now I want to be
really clear this is just a snapshot
it's a moment in time this is not about
Biden's got this it's not about staying
home in November it's not about Biden's
going to win the point is when I simply
say Trump's winning by seven in these 15
battleground states you then look at
each state you see wait a second Biden's
winning most of the states and most of
the electoral votes right now so polling
is valuable in two ways and this isn't
either of them polling is valuable to be
able to say what is one state look like
or polling is valuable to say what is
the national popular vote looking like
giving us what seems to be a blended
popular vote for 15 states where you
call them battlegrounds but some like
Georgia are not considered battleground
states it is deceptive it tells us
nothing and it actually fuels uncritical
reporting from left right and center
media outlets that only confuses people
even more let's not fall for it that's
why it's important to understand what
was done here make sure you're following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show lastly my personal
Instagram David Pakman I took apart a
whole watermelon yesterday posted it to
my Instagram and people are losing their
minds David that's not how you break
down a watermelon David you're using the
wrong kind of knife David your hair
looks stupid David I didn't know you
were left-handed that's really beta of
you check out the watermelon video on my
Instagram David got cocky
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
alright listen guys I've been debating
whether or not to do this segment over
the weekend because I don't want to
number one confuse people I don't want
to spread wrong information I don't want
to say something that might get somebody
to take a risky behavior or to put
people at risk of catching coronavirus
but at the same time it wouldn't be
honest for me to keep this information
from you and not to tell you about it
and not to get your thoughts on it so I
am coming to you today not to tell you
that I know what's going on with
lockdowns versus state reopening 'z but
merely to tell you there are clearly
things going on that we don't understand
or at least that I don't understand I
won't speak for others but I'll tell you
that I don't understand let me give you
an example California has been closed
for months
Texas reopened in late April their
curves for cases and deaths are looking
very very similar and again please
understand I'm not saying anything about
lock downs or reopening xym making no
medical or economic claims I am merely
saying something is not making sense and
I don't know what it is and I want to be
super careful because I want to learn
what it is that's going on so let's look
at California in Texas California and
Texas ordered lock downs right around
the same time it was about March 20th
from what we saw California's lockdown
was more strict than that in Texas and
California's lockdown seemed to be taken
more seriously by people in California
then the Texas law
down was taken by people living in Texas
the California lockdown has now been
going on two months Texas mostly started
reopening on April 28th I believe it was
we're gonna put the cases up on the
screen now there is no doubt that if you
look back to early May the Texas cases
have started to climb at a modest rate
and indeed when you look at raw numbers
Texas has had some of its higher
single-day new case numbers over the
last week or ten days but the curve is
not very different in Texas than it is
in California where you look at
California which has been unlocked down
for two full months now they also are
starting to see some of their highest
case numbers in the last week so I want
to be thorough here I can imagine
explaining this in a bunch of different
ways so let me give you one example have
the states simply been ramping up
testing and Texas has been ramping up
testing by more than California so the
increased cases are merely a result of
testing more well to some degree that's
true both California and Texas are
testing more now than they were at the
start of the lockdown so to some degree
you could say both California and Texas
are seeing more cases because they are
testing more but how does a state that's
been on a lockdown for two months have
an almost identical curve not raw
numbers but an almost identical curve to
a state that's been open for three weeks
I don't know I don't pretend to
understand now could it be that in Texas
even though they're open people are
still doing a lockdown and in California
even though they're still locked down
more people are ignoring the lockdown I
don't know I don't pretend to know what
if we look at deaths instead of cases
once again it looks similar the curves
are similar California has had way more
deaths in the aggregate California also
has more deaths per capita California
was an early hotspot it has more flights
to Asia more people coming back and
forth from Asia has a bigger population
but when we look at the curve the shape
of the curve we are seeing relatively
high numbers of deaths in California
about a plateau and it's not that
different
Texas had it highest death numbers about
a couple of weeks ago California had
them about four weeks ago so I don't
pretend to know what is going on but I
want to try to think through some of the
ideas I already mentioned the case
numbers are affected by testing maybe
the curves are similar because testing
has ramped up similarly and it's not
reflective of real case numbers that's a
possibility that's a possibility then
you look at deaths though and the curves
look similar
so maybe the deaths haven't yet peaked
in Texas and California's have peaked
are in a slow decline and right now
they're kind of crossing okay that's
possible maybe we'll know that in
another 10 or 14 days another argument I
saw maybe Texas is simply lying right
like okay I mean listen I don't put it
past them but in order to hide case and
death numbers while putting out fake
testing numbers or maybe the testing
numbers are real then that would mean
that the deaths and testing and the
deaths and cases are out of proportion
it's a coordinated conspiracy so I don't
listen we heard Florida was at one point
hiding cause of death it's a pretty big
conspiracy and I don't know that Texas
is even competent enough to get away
with it is it possible the heat is a
factor well it's hot in a lot of
California as well and it has been for
several months
do the lockdowns not work I mean now we
have information that show lockdowns do
reduce case numbers and deaths in the
aggregate but is it possible that
there's a natural curve the some kind of
natural timing to the virus that has a
similar trajectory regardless of policy
the lockdown saves people in numbers but
the trajectories end up being similar I
don't know I truly don't know there was
one paper that suggested that again I
mentioned is it possible that even
though California has stricter lockdown
and Texas is reopened maybe Californians
are ignoring it and some Texans are
staying home and it's sort of evening
out is there evidence of that I don't
know I'd I have no idea but what about
maybe I'm cherry-picking by only looking
at California and
okay let's compare to other states New
Jersey and Florida New Jersey is part of
the big New York hotspot and the big New
York lockdown Florida famously started
reopening stuff weeks ago the
trajectories for cases in Florida and
New Jersey are also very similar
certainly Florida hasn't seen the same
recent decline that New Jersey had but
they both went down for a bit and
they've both popped recently could it
just be testing well maybe but it's
still a similar trajectory looking at
deaths in New Jersey in Florida it's a
very similar curve now to be super clear
the numbers are different the death
numbers in Jersey are way higher they
were an early hotspot but the curves are
similar with similar timing so you know
I never lie to you I've noticed this I'm
bringing it to you and I want to know
more now the answer could be every place
is doing poorly because of the
disastrous federal response we have no
national contact tracing in place so
even the lockdowns only helped a little
bit I don't know I don't have the answer
but this is the data that I'm seeing I
want to hear from you what do you think
is going on here heading into the
weekend President Donald Trump announced
an upcoming new SuperDuper missile that
is not my term that's his asked of
excuse me asked about it his press
secretary Kaylee McKenna nee was saying
she doesn't know anything about it you
got to go talk to the Pentagon so late
last week Donald Trump had an event in
the Oval Office to announce the space
Force flag this is the newest sort of
sub branch of the military not really a
branch it encompasses the worst of
nationalism the military-industrial
complex unbridled capitalism and Trump's
delusions of grandeur all at one it puts
all of those together there was a really
funny moment when Trump went over to
take a picture with the space force flag
this is reality as far as we can tell
and something weird happened the guy
holding the flag sort of flinched and
almost dropped the flag Trump flinches
it's all a comedy of errors it's very
visual I admit but let's take a look at
it
that's fantastic
so that was something but to get to the
real disaster porn here is Trump
announcing the SuperDuper missile
incredible military equipment at a level
that nobody's ever seen before we have
no choice we have to do it with the
adversaries we have out there we have I
call it the SuperDuper missile and I
heard the other night 17 times faster
than what they have right now then you
take the fastest missile we have right
now you've heard Russia has five times
in China's working on five or six times
we have 117 times and it's just gotten
to go ahead 17 times faster if you can
believe that general that's something
right sounds like we could we could
really kill a bunch of people at once
with that thing I'm really really
exciting stuff so Trump says 17 times
faster than what we have right now so I
believe that our fastest missile right
now is the BrahMos also referred to as
the PJ 10 that is a maximum speed of
Mach 3 meaning about three times the
speed of sound
that's like 2,300 miles per hour so 17
times faster than that rough numbers
that's Mach 51 that would be about
39,000 miles per hour that sounds weird
I don't know about that about an hour
later Donald Trump's press secretary
Kelly McKenna nee was asked about this
the question alone was hilarious and
here's her answer super-duper missile
mr. Martin si declined to combat
referring back the White House so money
if you can say what the president was
describing yeah I would just refer you
back to the president mark remarks in
the Pentagon I don't have any new
information on that at this point so the
Pentagon as you heard they're referred
questions back to the White House White
House said nothing they said go back to
the Pentagon and eventually all that we
got out of the Pentagon was DoD is
working on developing a range of
hypersonic missiles no word on whether
it's 17 times faster than our current
fastest missile Nick Schifrin from PBS
Newshour said Trump maybe was referring
to the AGM 183 which is a hypersonic
missile approved for purchase by the air
force in February so there's some
obvious low-hanging fruit here like
Trump sounds like an idiot talking about
a super-duper missile there's
low-hanging fruit in this may be
classified Trump is again maybe being
irresponsible with classified info
that's nothing new
the real story for me here is look at
everything that's going on and we're
spending who knows how much money on
more new weapons that are marginally
better at killing more people more
quickly than what we have right now we
still don't have enough coronavirus
testing we still don't have a national
tracing initiative contact tracing
initiative for the virus we have people
who got 1,200 bucks and they are arguing
about whether anybody is going to even
get anything else although it's starting
to go in that direction
it's the latest just disgusting
enumeration of our misguided priorities
by the federal government and as usual
another day just another embarrassment
from Donald from just a chorus of
ridicule a barrage of embarrassment
after this once again the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
he continued war against a 79 year old
infectious disease doctor who has worked
for six presidents continues I'm talking
about dr. Anthony foul she continues to
be the target of protesters remember a
couple of weeks ago a chant of fire foul
she broke out at one of these reopen
protests here's the audio and video
reminder of that
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's getting even worse they're
going from fire foul Chi now two signs
that say hang foul Chi hang foul Chi
those have started to pop pop up at
protests here's one from a Long Island
New York protests over the weekend which
says hang foul Chi hang gates open up
all our states very poetic very nice
rhyming but completely horrifying Han
gates of course refers to Bill Gates
who's donating huge sums of his own
money to find a vaccine he's being
regularly attacked for it he's at the
center of multiple conspiracy theories
arguing that his intentions are actually
nefarious will there actually be any
accountability for the conspiracy
theorists that have spent months
spreading this nonsense because this is
a complete backslide from just basic
Enlightenment values now I want to be
careful because some of these
enlightened centrists and so-called
classical liberals they love to
fetishize talking about enlightenment
values and then they argue wildly that
the left on twitter is falling back from
enlightenment values by trying to do
things to prevent hate speech or
whatever we don't do that here okay I
don't know the last time I mentioned
enlightenment values this is not
something I've discussed that much
before but the anti science cesspool
that has become the coronavirus protests
it actually is a fight against basic
Enlightenment values of rationalist
philosophy a respect of science not
fetishizing science just a respect for
the scientific process and what it
provides us respect of the law
importantly so much of what we now take
for granted consider
that the terrorists don't have to attack
us anymore why would they we are
destroying ourselves from the inside as
this battle has been created between
those who understand and respect the
scientific process and who understand
what is an expert this is not about
phony experts but actually the
difference between dr. Anthony foutch II
and some guy on the internet with a blog
right and those who peddle conspiracies
and mass gather believe that they know
better than actual doctors this is not
the crisis of expertise which is
something I've not been shy about
covering imagine the same people rightly
criticizing the signs and the chance of
death to America elsewhere in the world
they are the same ones who chant fire
foul Chi and hold up signs that say hang
foul Chi we're doing the job of the
terrorists for them I would even go
further when it comes to the country
being united against the common enemy
after 9/11 you Americans were by and
large briefly united very united it
didn't last that long because George W
Bush turned 9/11 into a war against Iraq
which had nothing to do with 9/11 at all
but there was a period there the end of
2001 when George W Bush went to the
rubble at Ground Zero
his approval rating spiked I think it
was 86 or even 90% in late 2001 and the
country was united this could have
happened with coronavirus I've said it
before if on March 5th Trump makes an
FDR like speech I'm not endorsing
everything FDR did okay so before you
even start sending me messages about
that but an FDR like speech where he
speaks to the nation and says we have
difficult times ahead we do the
economics are going to be tough for a
little while but we must come together
we need stay at home from 50 governors
for 60 days you know maybe at the time
it would have been 30 and then it ends
up getting extended for 30 we're going
to come out on the other side we are
going to come out with few deaths we
will start to reopen and rebuild that
ship sailed
but with it also sailed the
administration may be presiding over a
rational reaction instead we've seen
Donald Trump sort of coyly support the
protesters drawing a line in the sand
separating his view from that of the
scientists criticizing everybody Under
the Sun about his own mishandling from
Obama to governor's to Democrats whoever
else while lying about testing and
everything else this doesn't bode well
for our future other countries are
realizing it I told you that their
laughter has mostly turned to horror and
pity at this point and I don't know how
we dig out of it my friends I really
don't over the weekend
Donald Trump's least intelligent son
that we are aware of that's Eric trump
made some completely ridiculous and
absolutely irresponsible comments he
went on Fox News to the program of judge
Jeanine Pirro and said just the series
of wacky things that were either lies or
wrong he also alleged a number of
baseless conspiracies so let's dive
right into the first clip here 76 days
to be exact away and listen by Biden
loves this Biden can't go on stage
without making some horrible blunder I
mean even from his basement he's making
awful gaffes every single day so his
campaigns thrilled that he's not going
out there and they think they're taking
away Donald Trump's greatest tool which
is being able to go into an arena and
fill it with 50,000 people every single
time right so they they will so Trump
was not filling arenas with 50,000
people this seems to run in the family
either everybody in the Trump family is
really bad at estimating crowd size or
everybody in the Trump family is
obsessed with lying about crowd size and
of course Trump was doing plenty of
rallies and many different events
regularly lying about the attendance but
he didn't have any 50,000 person rallies
and hilariously when I tweeted about
this someone said it was so predictable
David when he went to India more than
50,000 people came out to see him they
came out for their prime minister and
half the crowd left when it was Trump's
turned to speak but if you're one
example is from a different country then
you know that you're failing but this is
minor this is minor I want to focus on
the big thing here
the big lie the big conspiracy from Eric
Trump and you watch they'll milk it
every single day between now and
November 3rd and guess what after
November 3rd Crona virus will magically
all of a sudden go away and disappear
and everybody will be able reopen
they're trying to deprive him of his his
greatest asset which is the fact that
the American people love him the fact
that he's relatable the fact that he can
go out there a draw a massive crowds Joe
Biden can't get 10 people in a room my
father's getting 50,000 in a room so he
again mentions the 50,000 person crowd
thing that that's a lie
but most importantly Eric Trump says
after November 3rd the virus will
magically go away he suggests that the
entire global coronavirus pandemic is a
hoax to keep Donald Trump from having
rallies now here is what's absolutely
crazy about this this is actually what
Republicans did to Obama with Ebola in
2014 we had four cases of Ebola
diagnosed in the United States two of
those came from abroad we had two deaths
not 2% death we had two deaths from
Ebola in the United States and it was
all meant to be an attack on Obama the
day after the 2014 midterms go back and
check out my clips about this at the
time Republicans stopped talking about
Ebola altogether now the difference is
that wasn't a global pandemic this is
and yet Eric Trump believes the day
after the election this goes away then
Eric Trump wraps up his comment with
even more nonsense and they want to do
everything they can to stop it so make
no mistake to a lot of them Janine to a
lot of them this this is a very
cognisant strategy that they're trying
to employees no different than again the
nonsense that they're trying throwing
the hope Act it's no different than the
mail in voting that they want to do all
these places is no different than
wanting illegal immigrants to vote in
our country it is a cognisant strategy
and it's it's sad and again it's not
going to be allowed to happen we're
gonna win November okay and then Trump
goes on to say that reporters wearing
masks is also part of the conspiracy
if this wasn't Trump's son who you knew
was
nearly doing disinformation propaganda
you would question his mental state and
his connection to reality given the
wacky nature of what he's saying take a
look look at the White House press
conference yesterday they're all in
there there they're criticizing
everybody why isn't everybody wearing
masks why isn't everybody wearing masks
all of a sudden the press conference
ends they continue to roll clip and all
the reporters are ripping off their mass
in room and going up to each other and
speaking I mean it's it's really insane
I mean they're furthering their they're
actually stoking fear in this country
they're doing a massive disservice
they're being totally disingenuous about
the whole thing but they're doing it for
one reason they want to hurt Trump they
try to do with the Russia thing they try
to do it with you know the Ukraine
scandal they try to do with with
impeachment now they're trying to do it
with coronavirus they know that can't be
him they know that Joe Biden can't be I
mean doesn't he doesn't stand a chance
so what are they trying they're they're
trying to do anything that they can to
stop him they'll shut down the economy
they'll stop in-person voting so there
it is evidence that this is a totally
fake bogus hoax political scandal that
after a press briefing reporters removed
their masks real smoking gun you've got
there Eric now let me go back for a
moment it'll be over by November 3rd
because it's a hoax I already told you
this is what happened in 2014 with Ebola
you don't even need to go back to 2014
though go back to the 2018 midterms and
that caravan of dangerous criminal
illegal immigrants that we're going to
come here and kill and sexually assault
people back in 2018 the midterms went by
you didn't hear about it again this is
the utmost projection Democrats haven't
created the coronavirus hoax to hurt
Trump it's a global pandemic Republicans
really did turn Ebola which was a few
localized outbreaks into a political
weapon against Barack Obama Republicans
really did turn the immigrant caravan
which posed no threat or challenge to
our law enforcement at all in 2018 into
fear mongering to help Republicans in
the midterms they do that which they
accused Democrats of doing it's called
projection and Eric Trump sadly he's
just not as good as Donald Trump jr. at
convincing people with his lies it's
unfortunate
he's not the smart one that we know we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p here's just a
good question about so-called obama gate
take a livid i know the idea of obama
gate is ridiculous but with being put to
the test of specifics i don't have a
whole lot of answers other than it takes
more than just a president asking the
FBI to investigate a candidate for
something to happen you need judges to
approve warrants and stuff like that
could you help me with this
of course listen everything you're
saying is absolutely right but the
problem is you're allowing them to put
you on the defensive they are asserting
Barack Obama committed crimes get a list
of the crimes and the supporting
evidence and let's actually figure it
out don't feel as though you now have to
argue against this is like you know hey
listen there are invisible purple
elephants in the room with me right now
but they don't disturb the air they make
no noise what why why do you if I assert
that why is it you now that has to
disprove it I need to bring something to
the table we could say extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
apply whatever metaphor or proverb or
whatever you want to it don't allow them
to put you on the defensive let's start
with what are the crimes that Barack
Obama committed who else committed the
crimes let's look at the the the the
u.s. code of law and we'll go from there
don't fall for it otherwise we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
we talked months ago about producer
Pat's pandemic displacement part one and
it was crazy today we will bring you the
incredible story I didn't even believe
it when Pat emailed me about it of
producer Pat's pandemic displacement
Part two you will not believe what we
are going to tell you on today's bonus
show and also I have some prepping
updates that some of I know some of you
are going to laugh at me about but I'm
going to come clean I'm going to admit
the truth on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
join pakman.com
a patron at patreon.com slash david
package
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video